historiquement l'intelligence
artificielle était un domaine de
recherche qui s'intéressait à la
résolution de problèmes par des machines
on pensait que pour bien résoudre un
problème il fallait écrire le bon code
c'est à dire la bonne suite
d'instructions à suivre pour les
machines une certaine manière on avait
une approche assez déontologique pour
les machines on leur disait précisément
ce qu'elle devait faire
et ce qu'elle devait ne pas faire du
genre si tu connais la bonne réponse
s'affiche à l'écran sinon mais un écran
bleu mais au cours de la dernière
décennie
la roue a tourné aujourd'hui on préfère
l'apprentissage par l'exemple on donne
aux machines des tas de données et on
fait confiance aux machines pour
apprendre tout seul ce qu'elle doit
faire et ce qu'elles ne doivent pas
faire on parle parfois d' approche data
driven c'est-à-dire guidée par les
données ou encore de machines leur nez
et les succès du machine learning sont
nombreux et spectaculaires ainsi la
quasi-totalité des intelligences
artificielles de l'épisode 1 ne sont
autres que d'une machine learning
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui il semble
obsolète que de faire de l'intelligence
artificielle sans machine learning
mais ce succès retentissant soulève une
question d'envergure
on est tous d'accord pour dire que le
machine learning fonctionne super bien
en pratique
mais est ce que ça marche en théorie
est-ce que sur le papier le machine
learning fonctionne en croit certains il
s'agit de l'un des plus grands mystères
des sciences modernes ces dernières
années quant à magazine écrivait que le
machine learning fonctionne
spectaculairement bien les
mathématiciens ne savent pas trop
pourquoi
le woerthgate précisé que le diplôme
ning est en train de créer des systèmes
informatiques que ne comprenons pas
entièrement singularity aube a ajouté
que le monde dépend d'une technologie
que personne ne comprend alors que big
think confirmé que même les créateurs
des ja ne comprennent pas comment les ja
complexe marche
plus étonnant encore en décembre 2017
and it la plus grande conférence en
intelligence artificielle
à lire à amis chercheurs à google n'a
pas hésité à sortir les gros mots à ce
big rob a reculé
le machine learning est devenu de
l'alchimie at il affirmé
voilà qui aura particulièrement énervé
yann qu'un l'un des leaders mondiaux en
machine learning et s'en est suivi l'un
des clashs les plus académique du web
bref aujourd'hui il n'est pas scandaleux
pour un chercheur en iran que d'affirmer
que le succès du machine learning
mystérieux ils ont pas lu turing où les
clashs les chercheurs ni à son tour
blague à part je suis vraiment surpris
que si peu de chercheurs en venir mettre
en avant les travaux pourtant
révolutionnaire tales and turing en 1950
surtout la section 7 de cet article
parce que tout y est turing il ya
développé un argument théorique très
convaincant qui conclut que le machine
learning sera nécessairement la clé de
l'intelligence artificielle
autrement dit dans cet article fabuleux
il explique pourquoi sur le papier en
théorie le machine learning est voué à
fonctionner et ça ça répond tellement
bien at-elle mon interrogation autour de
la mystérieuse efficacité du machine
learning
alors je surtout pas vous donner
l'impression qu'il a aucun mystère
machine learning en a plein et on en
parlera mais ce que je prétends c'est
que le mystère du succès du machine
learning n'en est pas un
après tout alan turing l'avait prédit
pour des raisons purement théorique
dès 1950 et pourtant j'ai beau avoir
cherché la seule référence à la section
7 de cet article que j'ai trouvé une
note en bas de page de l'article
wikipédia anglophone
bon au moins dans cette note de bas de
page turing est en bonne compagnie très
très bonne compagnie mais bon je divague
aujourd'hui donc on va voir comment cet
article merveilleux qui était très très
très en avance sur son temps avait
quasiment t montrer plus value et la
nécessité d'une machine learning
dans la quête d'une intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui vous allez
découvrir quelque chose que de nombreux
experts on n'y a semble ignorer à savoir
la raison théorique pour laquelle le
machine learning a fini par surpasser
toutes les approches déontologique de
l'intelligence artificielle
on va voir pourquoi le futur de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
machine leur nez alors je laisse la
parole à turing le problème est surtout
un problème de programmation les
estimations de la capacité de stockage
du cerveau varient de 10 puissance 10 à
10 puissance 15 buts d'information je
serais surpris si plus de 10 puissance 9
était nécessaire pour jouer de manière
satisfaisante au jeu de limitation c'est
à dire aux thèses de turin not la
capacité de l'encyclopedia britannica
11e édition est 2 fois 10 puissance 9 à
mon rythme actuel de travail
je produis environ 1000 buts de
programmes par jour de sorte que 60
programmeurs travaillant de manière
régulière pendant 50 ans pourrait
accomplir la tâche en supposant que rien
ne finissent à la poubelle les méthodes
plus expéditive sont requises tout est
dans cette citation absolument
visionnaire la clé de l'argument de
turing tels que l'intelligence humaine
est un code informatique incroyablement
longs turing estime que la partie
incontournable de ce code fait plusieurs
giga octets mais surtout il sous-entend
que ce code est incompressible
autrement dit turing sous-entend
qu'aucun programme de moins d'un
gigaoctet ne parviendra à résoudre le
test de turing langage moderne de
l'informatique théorique
on dirait que le test de turing à une
complexité de kolmogorov de l'ordre du
giga octets en particulier turing va à
l'encontre d'un rêve de physicien qui
consisterait à réduire toute la
complexité de l'univers en une équation
d'une seule ligne pour turing il existe
des complexités essentiellement
incompressibles et l'intelligence
humaine en est un exemple
voilà qui explique d'ailleurs pourquoi
une intelligence artificielle qui serait
comparable à l'intelligence humaine ne
peut pas être décrite de manière précise
et succincte
en effet si le code de l'intelligence
artificielle est justement
incompressibles c'est justement qu'il
n'en existe pas de descriptions précises
plus courte puisque sinon cette
description précise plus courtes pourra
être utilisée pour générer
l'intelligence artificielle est passé le
test de turing
on aurait alors créer une intelligence
artificielle avec moins d'informations
l'incompressible complexité de
l'intelligence que turing postule être
de l'ordre du gigaoctet signifie que
toute description précise de
l'intelligence doit nécessairement faire
plusieurs milliers de gros bouquin
d'ailleurs l'existence de complexité
incompressible est sans doute l'un des
plus grands mystères de l'univers
mais bon là encore je divague mais
surtout la conséquence scotia du fait
que l'intelligence humaine soit
incompressibles c'est que programmer une
intelligence comparable à l'intelligence
humaine requiert nécessairement beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de lignes de codes des
milliards de lignes de code
si l'on en croit tuerie or de façon
pragmatique écrire des milliards de
lignes de code c'est super long et
difficile
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte de la longueur d'un tel programme
il serait aussi long que tout wikipédia
pour écrire un tel code il faudra
nécessairement collaborer en équipe
pendant des décennies sauf que des
décennies de travail en équipe surtout
quand l'équipe est grande
un conduit nécessairement à des
redondances des failles des bugs des
incompréhensions des réécritures voir
des engueulades des insultes et des
abandons
bref écrire un milliard de lignes de
code en équipe c'est le bordel à titre
de comparaison en mathématiques pures la
classification des groupes simple fini
et justement une sorte de maxime
collaboration entre des centaines de
mathématiciens de très haut vol qui
commença en 1955 et fut achevée en 2004
soit tout un demi siècle
le tout pour produire seulement des
dizaines de milliers de pages de preuves
dès qu'elles sont même probablement ou
pré cible a contrario écrire le milliard
de lignes de code incompressibles pour
résoudre le test de turing sa part est
complètement illusoire
même avec des milliers d'ingénieurs de
premier rang qui collaborerait pendant
des décennies on en arrive là à la
limite de la preuve déontologique de
l'intelligence artificielle
il est humainement impossible
d'expliciter clairement et sans
ambiguïté tout ce qu'il faut faire pour
paraître à peu près intelligent comme le
dit turing des méthodes plus expéditive
sont acquises
dans le processus d'essayer d'imiter un
esprit adulte humain nous faut bien
réfléchir au processus qui l'a amené
dans l'état où il est on peut remarquer
trois composants à l'état initial de
l'esprit disons à la naissance paix
l'éducation à laquelle il a été sujet
c'est les autres expériences autre que
l'éducation auquel il a été sujet lieu
d'essayer de produire un programme pour
imiter le cerveau adulte
pourquoi ne pas essayer d'en produire un
qui simule celui de l'enfant s'il était
ensuite sujet à une éducation appropriée
on obtiendrait alors un cerveau adulte
on peut supposer que le cerveau d'un
enfant ressemble incarné comme ce que
l'on achète aux papetiers plutôt peu de
mécanismes et beaucoup de feuilles
blanches
notre espoir est alors qu'il ya si peu
de mécanismes dans le cerveau d'un
enfant que celui ci est facile à
programmer
on a donc divisé notre problème de par
le programme enfants
si le processus d'éducation ainsi naquit
l'idée de machine learning plutôt de
leur nid machine dans la terminologie de
turing
récapitulons le merveilleux arguments de
turing turing imagine que le cerveau
humain se complexifie avec le temps si
c'est le cas ça veut dire que le cerveau
d'un enfant est probablement moins
complexe que le cerveau d'un adulte
turing postule que le cerveau de
l'enfant est une sorte de cahiers
vierges
alors je sens venir les psychologues
parmi vous oui en effet aujourd'hui on
pense que le cerveau d'un bébé est
davantage une machinerie bien huilée
qu'une feuille blanche
mais l'argument de turing qu'un
néanmoins cet argument c'est que le
cerveau de l'enfant est incompressible
ou du moins turing postule qui n'est
peut-être pas si difficile d'écrire un
code source avec les mêmes facultés
d'apprentissage que le cerveau de
l'enfant et par passé difficile
j'entends quelque chose de précis à
savoir le fait qu'il existe un programme
suffisamment court pour être écrit par
des ingénieurs en quelques mois disons
et qui génère quelque chose de semblable
au cerveau de l'enfant avec peut-être
quelques connaissances initiales mais
aussi et surtout avec la capacité de
s'auto complexifier suite à
l'apprentissage
turing comprend dès lors que le noeud de
la recherche en intelligence
artificielle ce qui permettra un jour
d'obtenir des il ya deux niveaux humain
voire surhumain c'est la conception de
ce programme initial ou dit autrement de
cette learning machine
il suffira ensuite de lui fournir un
enseignement appropriées pour que cette
learning machine s'auto complexifie et
atteignent des performances surhumaine
et urine prétend que cette approche est
voué à marcher
elle dispose d'un pouf of concept à
savoir le cerveau humain a cassé turing
en vient alors à la conclusion que le
machine learning est une condition
nécessaire et suffisante à la conception
par l'humain d'une intelligence
artificielle
ok c'est peut-être aller un petit peu
vite du coup je vais reformuler un peu
les arguments de turing notamment parce
que c'est un des plus beaux raisonnement
que je connaisse la première chose c'est
que l'intelligence notamment celles
requises pour le test de turing au caire
une grande complexité de kolmogorov sans
doute de l'ordre du gigaoctet
du coup numéro deux il faut donc
programmé un très long code informatique
incompressibles pour concevoir une
intelligence artificielle
or 3 il est humainement impossible
d'écrire des codes informatiques
incompressibles s'ils ont du coup quatre
toute méthode capable de générer de tels
codes obtiendra des facultés qu'aucun
code informatique programmée par des
humains ne pourra acquérir
or 5 il semble que l'apprentissage
permet bel et bien d'obtenir de telle
complexité de kolmogorov l'exemple du
cerveau humain le montre du coup 6 les
learning machines sont indispensables à
l'intelligence artificielle en
particulier turing à la une réponse
toute faite à la question comment
expliquer le succès d'une machine
learning sa réponse si je la refais
formule c'est que seul le machine
learning permet l'exploration de
l'espace des algorithmes à grande
complexité de kolmogorov le machine
learning permet donc de faire des choses
très utile qu'aucune autre méthode ne
saura faire et c'est pour ça qu'en 1950
turing a affirmé qu en théorie le
machine learning ça marche
la dernière fois on a parlé de
l'importance de la logique pour
l'intelligence et nixon corriger une
erreur que j'ai faite sur le nombre de
particules dans un verre d'eau mea culpa
mais ça ne prenne ce qu'il ya aussi
envoyé vers un lien de wells loeb qui
expliquent l'histoire de tartaglia et de
ces équations du troisième et du
quatrième degré clément patients dont je
recommande vivement la vidéo de welch
allyn donc la vidéo est en anglais il ya
ludovic il devrait être aussi qu'il
propose un lien vers un article est
écrit par michael launay qui parle aussi
de tarte à venir nicolas schmit se
demande si notre impossibilité à simuler
notre univers en temps réel à l'inter de
notre univers fait que les situations à
la black mirror sont nécessairement faux
pas vraiment la situation n'en est pas
du tout invalidé en fait qu'on ne puisse
pas simulé l'univers plus rapidement que
l'une
à l'intérieur de l'univers on peut tout
simplement voir des simulations dont une
seconde à l'intérieur de l'univers
correspond en fait peut-être des
milliards d'années dans notre annuaire
physique
plus généralement il semble que des
simulations dans des simulations dans
des simulations ça fait perdre un peu de
complexité algorithmique et de
complexité de kolmogorov typiquement à
chaque fois qu'il ya un univers l'inter
dans notre univers est bon tout ça un
petit peu spéculatif autre chose pour
donner des sensations de réalisme on
n'est pas obligé de simuler tout
l'univers ou de simuler tous les temps
de planck on peut peut-être faire des
approximations pour que l'univers
simuler ressemble à l'univers que l'on
connaît bien ayant en particulier
l'épisode de noël de black mirror il
peut être pas si irréaliste que ça en
tout cas j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils
soient vraiment incompatibles avec les
lois de la physique et la thèse toutes
sortes tuerie vous avez est un peu
perplexe par rapport à l'irréductibilité
algorithmique en effet il ya beaucoup de
calculs par exemple le calcul qui
propose en descriptions dont on peut en
fait trouver des short cut des
courts-circuits éviter de faire tous les
calculs donc par exemple on avait vu
dans une vidéo qu'un +2 plus propre
samedi est le premier membre entier
naturel est égale à une fois elle pu
seulement divisé par deux et ce qu'elle
julen fois une puce 1 / 2 est beaucoup
plus rapide que la somme de tous les
entier on avait parlé aussi dans un
défilé alors oui en effet il ya beaucoup
de calcul dont on peut trouver des
raccourcis de calcul et éviter de faire
tout le calcul pour trouver le résultat
est ce que l'irréductibilité
algorithmique dit c'est que l'ensemble
de ces problèmes est en fait un ensemble
de cas très particulier et que en
général si on point un système qui est
tu as une complet et on prend dans des
conditions initiales qui sont aléatoires
arbitraire en général il sera impossible
de trouver des raccourcis de calcul
mathieu pose la question de l'importance
de l'erreur pour les intelligences
artificielles comme pour l'intelligence
humaine d'ailleurs je pense que les
erreurs sont très très très importantes
et elles sont d'ailleurs programmées
dans pas mal de d'accueil de machine
learning que ça dépend comment on me
disait erreur après clair de savoir ce
que ce qu'elle est vraiment mais thomas
on avait notamment parlé dans la phase
d'exploration notamment
les algorithmes de colonies de fourmis
mais plus généralement il ya ce problème
classique de machines en u qui est le
dilemme exploration et exploitation que
ça correspond en particulier un sous
domaine du machine learning qu'on
appelle le online machine learning
il y aura énormément plus à dire dans
bref oui dans une phase d'exploration il
faut encourager les erreurs potentielles
tengoku nous demandent s'il faut
finalement pas voir la logique comme un
outil plutôt qu'une fin en soi et je
pense en effet en étant assez
constructif je suis assez
constructiviste comme mathématicien je
pense en effet que la logique ne doit
être vue comme un outil absolument pas
comme une vérité fondamentale mais
encore une fois et je vous renvoie
notamment vers un épisode de la série
sur un fini beaucoup de mathématiciens
dit platonicien ne seraient pas d'accord
avec moi je dirais qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose vérité sous la tente qui
est absolument merveilleuses à découvert
et tout ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le fait que l'univers qui est créé
par une certaine logique peut être
absolument merveilleux en tant que tel
reste que je pense que ces vérités ces
mondes idéaux sont complètement
déconnectés de la réalité physique et
que pour pouvoir faire des trucs
intéressants dans la réalité physique et
il ya déjà énormément des choses très
intéressantes
il est plus utile et je pense avoir une
approche plus instrumentaliste
c'est-à-dire considéré plus la logique
comme un outil ben arfa faisait aussi
posé le défi impossible et qui
consistait à définir le mot structure
one that's artistes nous proposent une
définition qui mêle un petit peu des
idées d'un ensemble qui arrive à être
cohérents et que l'on peut décrire
d'oppression microscopiques mais bien
sûr tous ces maux sont assez imprécis et
d'ailleurs ils se rencontrent dans sa
définition et sont en fait c'est un
poème très difficile c'est un peu le but
recherché si vous étiez vraiment de
définir tous les mots que vous utilisez
dans la définition on en vient vite à la
constatation qu'en fait c'est un point
très difficile alors du coup il ya des
reproches beaucoup plus simpliste qui
consiste à dire que une structure c'est
juste un ensemble d'éléments qui peut
être intéressant entre eux mais si on y
réfléchit on sent moins quand même qu'il
ya des ensembles de trucs dans le jeu de
la vie qu'on n'a pas forcément envie
d'appeler des structures parce que c'est
tellement le bordel que l'impression
qu'il ya pas de structure une idée de
koenig et de serge poulin c'est le fait
que la structure doit forcément être usé
d'une certaine manière derrière leur
définition une certaine idée de
connexité mais si on regarde pas dans
des canons à planeur ce compte que c'est
pas des structures qui sont en tout cas
connexes au sens mathématique d'ailleurs
que d'une certaine manière il y a
un trou entre deux parties de la
structure et mais quand même envie de
dire que même si la structure est
composée de plusieurs composantes
connect l envie de dire que ça reste
quand même une structure en tant que tel
globalement on en vient à l'elysée de
bach aux pierres swing et fier 0,34
parmi d'autres du pas mal de
commentaires du coup j'ai pas pu faire
des listes exhaustives mais lydia chaque
fois dans ses commentaires ses deux
d'identifier une sous région de l'espace
qui a l'air d'une certaine manière assez
indépendant du reste de l'espace qui
d'une certaine manière c'est la
séparation entre cet objet interne et le
reste de l'univers qui fait qu'on peut
appeler c'est au gré interne une
structure alors c'est vraiment pas mal
comme des d'ailleurs il ya des
chercheurs en biologie notamment carl
rinsch stone qui essaie d'identifier le
vivent comme étant quelque chose qu'on
est capable de séparer à travers
notamment par exemple une membrane
cellulaire du monde extérieur
il ya même une formalisation
mathématiques un peu plus rigoureuse et
tout ça il consiste à raisonner en
termes de couverture de markov
mais là encore cette définition on peut
un peu la critique et en disant bas il
ya quand même des relations avec le
monde extérieur même si elles sont peut
être moindre que pour une région de
l'espace prises au hasard
et là encore il ya des trucs qui sont un
peu n'importe quoi action assez
séparables du monde extérieur mais qu'on
n'a peut-être pas forcément envie
d'appeler structure en tout cas ce que
je trouve amusant dans ma propre façon
de réfléchir c'est qu'à chaque fois la
manière dont j'essaie de parler de vos
définitions
c'est à travers d'exemples et si on y
réfléchit on se rend compte que la
manière dont on a appris ce qu'était une
structure même instinctivement en fait
c'est uniquement par exemple puisqu'on
n'a jamais lu de définition formelle de
la structure et son cgem il y obtient ça
c'est la définition formelle du mot
structure on à un ferrer à chaque fois
ce qui était que la notion de structures
en voyant beaucoup d'exemples et du coup
ça me permet de faire le lien avec la
vidéo que vous venez de voir puisque
d'après turing la meilleure façon
d'apprendre à une assurance artificiers
à ce qu'est qu'une structure ou un chat
ou un chien ou ce que vous voulez c'est
en raisonnant uniquement à partir
d'exemples et en inférant à partir de
ces exemples quelque chose qui ensuite
correspond aux nombreux exemples de
chiens de chats ou structures que l'on a
vu visionnaire et 7,7 nous fait
d'ailleurs la remarque que pour la
définition d'un truc aussi simple qu'un
tas alors en fait on a beaucoup de
problèmes ils avaient un accent de
vidéos de dirty baloji sur le problème
de ces finitions puisque formant imposer
une frontière une limite mais quand on
définir le nombre n de grain de sable
pour que
lorsqu'on a moins de haine grain de
sable n'a pas de ta alors lorsqu'on a bu
de n1 tard briand ne sera pas d'accord
sur la valeur de m du coup la définition
même de ce qu'est un tas est assez floue
ça n'empêche pas le concept est d'être
utile en pratique alors je parle bien
sûr de tapas que c'est un truc un
exemple assez simple à ces visuels mais
surtout qu'ils ne veuillent pas lui
kahnisme en nous mais dès qu'il faut
définir des trucs plus sophistiqués
comme qu'est ce que la démocratie
forcément ça devient vraiment vraiment
beaucoup plus compliqué d'ailleurs comme
le propose au chili tenda il ya un
exercice de style de très intéressant
qui consistait à partir d'une phrase
assez banal comme le chat - chez la
souris ou dans l'autre cas va partir de
la phrase c'est une structure qui avance
et remplacer les mots de cette phrase
par leur définition dans le dictionnaire
donc j'ai fait ça avec la phrase c'est
une structure qui avance et juste avec
le mot structure et une rotation de nos
structures qu'après une itération ça me
donne c'est une disposition des parties
d'un tout constituant une sorte d'
architecture de construction qui
avancent donc cette définition
l'impression qu'elle clarifie absolument
rien voir qu elle complexifie encore
plus le truc et c'est encore plus le cas
si on applique deuxième itération en
passant chacun des mots de la définition
du mot structure par leur définition
dans le dictionnaire
donc j'ai utilisé le wiktionnaire et à
chaque fois j'ai choisi la définition
dans le dictionnaire qui me semblait la
plus pertinente mais au bout de deux
itérations ça me bloque déjà c'est une
manière dont une chose est mise dans
l'ordre la plus convenable des portions
de ceux qui corresponde d'intégrité dont
il refait la totalité d'une chose
considéré par rapport au nombre et
l'étendue ou à l'intensité de l'énergie
constituant une sorte de façon dont une
chose est ordonnée d'assemblage de
disposition des matériaux des diverses
parties d'un édifice qui avance tout ça
pour dire que les définitions du
dictionnaire en fait pas du tout
rigoureuse et elle clarifie pas du tout
les choses parce qu'elle soit ce réflexe
de se dire bon bah on connaît pas la
définition amour est ce qu'on va la
trouver
on va chercher dans le dictionnaire en
fait si on regarde la définition
dictionnaire elle renvoie tellement
d'autres mots qui renvoie a tellement
d'autres mots ayant ici on déplie un peu
le schmilblick on obtient un truc
complètement incompréhensible plus
généralement tout ceci vient en fait du
point des définitions circulaire ils
vous envoient vers l'excellence vidéo de
monsieur fille sur les actions de khalid
qui explique très bien tout ça en fait
on l'a vu notamment dans la série sur
l'infini lorsqu'on essaie de bien poser
des définitions comme ça en fait ce qui
est intéressant c'est une relation entre
les mots sauf que si on essaie de
construire ses relations entre ces mots
j'invite des trucs complètement
incompréhensible du coup la construction
du langage naturel à partir de règles
formelles c'est juste un truc qui n'est
pas faisable
humainement et en fait on pourrait
imaginer que la seule façon d'avoir des
définitions rigoureuse qui parle
vraiment de quelques trucs fondamentaux
comme des 0 et des 1 et qui permet
ensuite de construire ils ont une
fonction qui à chaque fois qu'on lui
montre une photo de chadi à sacha notre
photo je vais a dit ça c'est pas un chat
la seule façon de construire cette
fonction là pour que cette fonction soit
défini de façon non ambiguë est grosse
même s'ils avaient pas forcément
parfaite parfois ça secoue cette
fonction elle va dire qu'un truc et
recharge à rien de construire cette
fonction est absolument difficile et
sans doute même que le code source le
plus court de cette fonction-là fait
forcément peut-être pas des milliards
mais peut-être des milliers voire des
millions de lignes de code
un truc qui ne serait pas du tout
lisible par l'humain et qui sera encore
plus dur à écrire pour un humain au
final de façon pragmatique peut-être la
meilleure définition de ce qu'est une
structure c'est celle que oppose c est
moi et corrigée en gros une structure au
final ce que c'est vraiment et bien une
structure c'est un truc intéressant
on n'a quasiment rien dit quand on dit
ça puisqu'il faut encore définir ce
qu'est un intéressant truc c'est juste
ma chasse et du sein bejune cesu se
faire référence à quelque chose et si ce
quelque chose d intéressant on peut
peut-être appeler ça une structure la
grosse difficulté bien sûr c'est de
définir le mot intéressante
j'ai envie de dire que de façon
pragmatique ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce qui permet de décrire ou de faire des
prédictions
autrement dit si j'ai d'abord un petit
peu plus cette définition je ne dirais
qu'une structure
c'est un composant important d'un modèle
voilà je pense que de façon pragmatique
c'est difficile finalement de faire bien
mieux que ça mais moi je suis sûr qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
d'accord le cas des fils de cuivre de
données et j'espère que vous avez aimé
cet épisode qui conclut un peu le début
de cette série qui parlait pas mal
l'algorithmique et de concept derrière
le calcul qui je pense sont vraiment
indispensables pour comprendre le succès
du match énorme et on a tendance à dire
que machine learning c'est juste trouver
des corrélations dans les gommer et si
on pense que la machine learning c'est
ça les voiliers à être surpris par le
succès demain
ce qui est amusant c'est que tu as une
approche complètement différente de
celle horning machines' encore de passer
le premier à introduire cette idée de
machinerie pour turing ça semble être
davantage une exploration de l'espace
des algorithmes à forte complexité qu'on
peut pas exploré autrement autrement dit
à la tuerie on peut voir le machine
learning comme étant une automatisation
de l'écriture de code et si on voit le
machine learning en tant que tel je
pense que le succès du mât chinois est
beaucoup moins surprenant plus
généralement cette élection 7 notamment
de l'article de turing 2050 est
absolument fabuleux je pense qu'il
introduit pas mal d'idées qui serait
utile plus tard notamment par exemple
les algorithmes génétiques ont le truc
c'est que c'est un peu un article très
vulgariser qui s'adresse pas forcément
des informaticiens du coup y'a pas plein
de formalisation mathématiques et tout
ça mais les quantités sont déjà dans cet
article pour tendre très très prévenants
allez le lire
j'en profite aussi pour mentionner
rapidement rei solomonoff qui est pour
moi le grand grand grand génie de
l'intelligence artificielle d une
machine roues et qui je pense que
devrait être beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus connus s'il ne l'est
malheureusement en gros je pense que
soldat fait simplement résolu le premier
machine mim avec notre pays viennent
malheureusement dans cette série je ne
parlais pas d' approche parisienne du
coup je ne parlerai pas de ça j'ai
vraiment sur le ménage dans la suite des
idées c'est vraiment la suite naturelle
des idées de turing donc on peut voir un
peu seul au sommet comme la confession
des idées et des tueries enfin pour ceux
qui veulent en savoir plus son corps se
retiennent yad vashem des signes d'une
banane a sorti une vidéo où il lit un
texte une tuerie a lu sur la radio bbc
dans les années 50
et c'est un document absolument
merveilleux qui est tellement le
comprendre plus les débats qui avaient à
l'époque
et pourquoi est ce culturel est
incroyablement en avance sur son temps
vraiment turing crg ni la semaine
prochaine et pour les prochaines
dizaines de vidéos quelque chose comme
ça on va parler de machine learning
théorique enseignée aujourd'hui tels que
c'est enseigner aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
très très proches du coût des notions
tactiques pas mal parlé aussi des deux
statistiques leur footing et tout ça et
en particulier la semaine prochaine on
va parler de l'importance de la mémoire
et on verra notamment que le mémoire ne
suffit pas grave on pourrait croire
naïvement être intelligent bien
comprendre le monde
ce n'est pas mémoriser des faits et des
connaissances si vous avez aimé cet
épisode penser à le laïcat le comique
avait partagé par ça vous y revenez pour
présenter les futurs épisodes merci aux
supporteurs dont il espère qu'il serait
là la prochaine fois faites il ya un
autre chercheur qui selon mme nov qui
est l'autre grand gagnant de l'histoire
côté de la classe cc solide nov
l'idée de seulement 9 c'est d'imaginer
toutes les probabilités calculable
possible
woodside